unicorn chikomo has a master's degree in
international trade law but finding a
job in Zimbabwe is difficult
so in 2018 he became a farmer and now
employs several people the 30 year old
is one part of a new generation of
educated youths who work the land to
create livelihoods but navigating the
country's farming industry isn't easy
the biggest challenge we've got is an
issue of financial capital
and for even young people
to be able to walk into a bank you've
got no collateral
you've got probably no
history or you've got no storied line to
tell how viable your business or your
idea is
and also even the access to to land
the state some banks and the private
sector help Finance Farmers but many say
they can't get the help they need to get
started this country has a lot of
fertile land but since Land Reform when
commercial farmers were seized from
White and given to Black zimbabweans
some of that land is not being fully
utilized more young people here say they
can help increase productivity
in another part of the country Valerie
madziva and her husband are preparing to
export watermelons to the Middle East
Zimbabwe is strategically located
because most of this project they are
getting it from Australia and Brazil
Zimbabwe is just 21 to 28 days to Dubai
whereas when you look at Brazil they are
looking at over 35 days on water old
infrastructure electricity shortages and
an inflation rate of more than 200
percent are some of the factors holding
back Zimbabwe's Farmers it really
depends on the performance of the
economy whether the youths are going to
be successful
it really depends on the performance of
the economies the economy improves so
that the profit prospects of farmers
Valerie believes farming could be one
solution to the country's unemployment
problem but young people say for that to
work they must have access to the
resources they need to thrive Haru
matasa Al Jazeera goromonzi District
Zimbabwe